the score serve as a musical through
line that impacts our feelings in any
given scene like when we hear this
oscar-winning score
I know it's time to take max out the
water because probably something bad is
gonna happen in ocean but wait you can
swim right yeah why would you ask me
just because unfortunately a lot of
people don't know that about us ah
Touche Touche or how about when you hit
this
[Music]
we know people are going to fall in love
before something else bad happens in the
ocean a great score moves us as an
audience while reminding us that really
bad things can happen in the ocean here
are the nominees for Best Original Score
[Music]
black panther by Ludwig Lorenz
[Music]
by Terence Blanchard
if Beale Street could talk by Nicolaus
Patel
I love dogs by Alexandre disco
MARY POPPINS returns by Marc Shaiman and
the Oscar goes to
Ludovic Korres and Sarah
[Music]
this is the first Oscar and nomination
[Music]
[Music]
well thank you Ryan Coogler Ryan Ryan
working with you has been an incredible
honor
I remember 12 years ago we're sitting in
our dorm at USC writing your first two
score for your first short film and
we're here 12 years later you know
celebrating one of the most important
cinematic moments in history um I want
to share this award with all the
incredible African orchids artists that
I worked with on score ba ba ma ma
somebody up maggots aw and all the
classical musicians in London they
recorded on the score and everyone I
also want to share this award with my
mom and dad and sister they insisted I
play guitar and my wife Serena I love
you so much thank you
[Applause]